[Musique]
oui c'est Jean-Luc et baé comme les anes
et ça s'écrit pareil ici on a la petite
ferme paysane qui situ à archini dans
une une zone naturelle protégée c'est
une petite ferme qui fait 5 hectares et
je travaille toutes mes terres avec mes
deux anes et je travaille
essentiellement avec mes en attacction
animale pour produit des légumes de
saison j'ai pas de ser sur la ferme
juste une petite ser pour faire mes
plans et j'essaie de faire au mieux en
respectant bah les saisons le temps la
biodiversité c'est pour ça que chez moi
il y a un peu d'herbe mais c'est fait
exprès voilà respecter le temps des
animaux le le leur façon de leur rythme
voilà travailler vraiment au rythme de
l'animal et de la nature et tous mes
légumes sont produit sur des petites
butes qui s'appellent des billons donc
mes billons font 65 cm de large sur 45 m
de long le billon ça vient une technique
africaine qui en fait
protège protège les légumes au niveau de
soit de l'humidité ou soit de la chaleur
tous mes légumes sont traités avec des
extraits de plantes
fermentées que je fabrique moi-même
alors en légumes j'ai enfin je fais
beaucoup de Pom enfin pomme de terre
carotes oignons ail
échalotte poireau ça ce sont des des des
légumes qui se travaillent bien en
traction animale ouis c'est bien ça et
et après je je vais avoir après tout ce
qui est légumes d'été tomate voilà tout
les légumes d'été quoi mais c'est vrai
que là dans dans les années à venir j'ai
peut-être beaucoup plus accentué sur
tout ce qui est légumes divivers qui se
travaille beaucoup plus facilement avec
les avec les voilà ben je travaille
beaucoup en en circuit court euh j'ai
ben j'ai j'ai un restaurant qui me prend
des légumes à la roche posée j'ai la
petite supérette à archiniie qui me
prend des légumes également après en ce
moment avec des collègues paysans nous
sommes en train de développer un un site
qui s'appelle le déclic paysan et où on
va retrouver tous les produits de on est
plusieurs paysans à faire plusieurs
choses don des légumes du pain du
laitfin de la viande et là en fait sur
ce sur ce sur ce site là les gens
pouront créer le le propre panier en
prenant en piochant chez chez un peu
tous les producteurs dont ils vont le
voir et après les légumes enfin les
paniers seront mis sur un point de de
dépôt du restaurant du clopiller la
roche posée n'oubliez pas je suis à de
PES de chez
vous